Traduttore: Carlo Schiatti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io e Simone condividiamo tutto nella vita,
siamo partner nella vita e nel lavoro.
Ed è così che, vivendo insieme,
ci capita di andarci
a trovare l'un l'altro,
uno nello studio dell'altro, e di dire:
"Ti vanno un paio di spaghetti? ",
oppure di dire "Ti va di fare due passi?"
oppure, come è successo una volta,
che Simone è venuto da me e mi ha detto
"Ti va di fare un'edizione collettiva
dell'Amleto di Shakespeare? "
Ed è così che, da quando
abbiamo avuto questa idea,
da quando Simone ha avuto questa idea,
abbiamo messo da parte
le paste e le passeggiate
e ci siamo dedicati a questo progetto
che è cresciuto molto velocemente.
Che cos'è, allora, "The Global Hamlet"?
The Global Hamlet è la prima edizione
di una traduzione popolare,
e un apparato critico collettivo,
che sia mai stata realizzata
di un'opera letteraria.
Come funziona?
Funziona come tutto il mondo,
che traduce, annota in molte lingue
l'Amleto di Shakespeare.
Per ora le lingue che abbiamo raccolto
sono il francese, lo spagnolo,
l'italiano, l'olandese
e anche l'inglese per la versione
dell'annotazione dell'illustrazione.
Tutti quindi potranno partecipare,
è aperta a tutti la partecipazione,
in base alle proprie inclinazioni
e ai propri interessi,
e anche per assecondare
quello che è un aspetto
educativo fondamentale
di questo grande esperimento,
abbiamo raccolto intorno a noi
una serie di istituzioni,
e di università, in tutto il mondo.
Per ora ne abbiamo raccolte
moltissime in Italia,
abbiamo raccolto La Sapienza,
l'Università di Utrecht in Olanda,
a Parigi, in Spagna,
in Inghilterra istituzioni come la
"National Operatic
and Dramatic Association".
Insomma, tutta una serie di associazioni
che ci aiutano a creare
la struttura portante di questo progetto.
SB: Quali sono, allora,
le due anime di questo progetto,
le sue due matrici?
Una è una matrice teatrale,
un'altra è una matrice tecnologica.
Una è un'anima umanistica,
e l'altra è un'anima scientifica.
La nostra ambizione
è quella di riuscire
ad amalgamarle in questo progetto,
così come sono amalgamate
nel nome del progetto:
The Global Hamlet.
The Global Hamlet fa riferimento,
naturalmente, al Globe Theater,
il teatro fondato
da William Shakespeare a Londra
e dove fu rappresentato l'Amleto;
ma fa riferimento, anche,
ad un significato particolare
della parola "hamlet", cioè villaggio.
Quindi "Global Hamlet"
vuol dire villaggio globale
ed è come se ci fosse
un letterale avveramento
del motto shakesperiano
"All the world is a stage",
tutto il mondo è teatro.
Perché, in sostanza, il logo
di Global Hamlet è proprio questo,
rappresenta il Globe Teather
che si apre ed ingloba in sé il mondo,
che si fa mondo.
D'altra parte, questa interpretazione
era stata già pensata da Shakespeare,
quando aveva chiamato
il suo teatro "Globe",
proprio per rappresentare
che tutto il mondo è teatro
e il mondo è teatrale.
Questa dimensione collettiva
dell'Amleto di Shakespeare
è non soltanto
nella sua ricreazione attuale,
ma già nell'atto della creazione.
L'Amleto è una delle grandi opere
che possiamo considerare
"collettive" dell'umanità,
perché Shakespeare riceve
un canovaccio, una storia
che risale addirittura ai miti indoeuropei
e che passa attraverso
moltissime rielaborazioni, narrazioni.
Una delle quali, per esempio,
è di Tito Livio,
altre sono di autori inglesi e francesi;
e quando Shakespeare la riceve
e la riscrive, la rielabora,
si serve, si avvale
della collaborazione degli artisti,
degli attori della sua compagnia teatrale.
Quanto della figura di Amleto
dobbiamo al primo attore
che ha interpretato l'Amleto,
l'istrionico e geniale Richard Burbage,
che lavorò molto con Shakespeare
per costruire questo ruolo,
e quanto dobbiamo alla tradizione
editoriale dell'Amleto,
dato che non esistono versioni manoscritte
di Shakespeare dell'Amleto,
come non esiste
in nessuna delle sue opere;
e tutte le sue opere
sono state trascritte,
ricevute da copioni teatrali
che sono passati attraverso correzioni,
revisioni e così via;
e quanto dobbiamo,
addirittura, al pubblico,
che ha applaudito magari una scena
e si è annoiato in un'altra,
così suggerendo ai suoi autori
di rivedere certe parti del testo.
Un altro dei motivi
particolarmente importanti
per cui abbiamo voluto scegliere l'Amleto
è che l'Amleto è l'opera
in cui nasce la razionalità occidentale.
Non ci sarebbe Internet,
se non ci fosse Amleto,
si potrebbe dire così,
in modo provocatorio.
L'Amleto è l'opera che segna la divisione
tra l'età della tecnica,
che viene dall'uomo
e l'età della tecnologia,
che viene da se stessa,
che è tecnica per la tecnica;
e in Amleto la ragione è per la ragione,
la ragione pensa se stessa,
ragiona su se stessa, oltre che sul mondo,
dimostra la sua capacità
di autosufficienza
e la sua capacità di autodistruzione.
Abbiamo scelto l'Amleto
perché Harold Bloom ha detto, una volta,
che tutti gli uomini antichi
sono figli di Adamo
e che tutti gli uomini moderni
sono figli di Amleto.
E quindi ci piace pensare
che traducendo, annotando,
recitando e quindi interpretando l'Amleto,
il mondo stia anche scrivendo
la sua genealogia.
NM: E allora come si scriverà,
quest'opera, come verrà scritta?
Abbiamo visto chi la scriverà
e la scriveranno tutti,
la potrete scrivere tutti voi,
secondo le vostre inclinazioni,
le vostre passioni e le vostre conoscenze.
Non sarà assolutamente necessario
che voi abbiate delle conoscenze
approfondite o accademiche
in ambito shakesperiano,
in ambito di letteratura inglese;
e nemmeno che conosciate
a perfezione l'inglese,
perché ci saranno
una serie di strumenti, nel sito,
che permetteranno di approfondire
e di comprendere più precisamente
come si svolgerà questa operazione.
Qui vi faccio vedere un po' del sito,
che non è ancora on line
ma potrete vedere un po'
come si svolge, come è strutturato.
All'interno del sito,
voi potrete aggiungere
delle traduzioni e delle annotazioni,
oppure delle illustrazioni.
Le traduzioni si svolgeranno
attraverso una mascherina,
che voi potrete vedere,
comparirà qui ad un certo punto
e dentro la mascherina
sarà come scrivere dentro un blog,
quando voi mettete il vostro nome
e poi il vostro commento.
Questo commento sarà, per esempio,
la traduzione che voi vorrete proporre
e verrà proposta a un editor,
che la controllerà
e che quindi vaglierà la bontà,
o la non bontà, della vostra proposizione.
L'editor sarà anche un traduttore famoso,
ma non avrà la facoltà
di tradurre lui stesso
o di proporre una annotazione lui stesso;
quello che potrà fare sarà mettere insieme
parti delle traduzioni
che voi presenterete,
perché anche gli errori
saranno importantissimi,
saranno portatori di valore aggiunto,
perché delle volte è dagli errori
che nascono le cose più interessanti
e anche dalle ingenuità,
o dalle invenzioni che vengono proposte.
Quindi si potrà fare una proposta
attraverso una traduzione,
oppure si potrà proporre
un'annotazione, un commento.
Allora questo commento
potrà essere di vario tipo,
sempre attraverso le vostre inclinazioni,
le vostre conoscenze.
Se avete una passione particolare
per la psicologia,
potreste analizzare
tutti i meandri più profondi
della strana e scura
personalità di Amleto,
il suo rapporto con il padre,
il rapporto conflittuale con la madre;
oppure, se avete delle preferenze
in campo giuridico,
potreste analizzare come è avvenuto
il seppellimento di Ofelia,
che era una suicida.
Questi commenti li potrete fare
sia in forma scritta,
in modo tradizionale,
che in modo innovativo,
cioè mettere dei video,
delle immagini, delle musiche.
Per tutte queste cose,
per esempio per la musica
e il commento alla musica,
ci sarà una cosa che ci piace chiamare
la "colonna sonora"
di questa operazione, di questo sito
e che sarà la versione,
sia in inglese elisabettiano
che in inglese contemporaneo,
di tutto l'Amleto letto dagli attori.
Quindi potrete anche commentare
questa colonna sonora con vostri commenti,
oppure potrete sottoporre
delle illustrazioni fatte da voi,
non solo riferendovi a quelle
dell'iconografia classica amletica,
ma quelle che voi vorrete proporre;
e queste verranno messe
al vaglio di altri editor
e potrebbero essere
pubblicate, poi, sul sito,
in una sezione che si chiama Pinacoteca.
Ci saranno varie sezioni
che caratterizzeranno questo sito.
Nella Pinacoteca ci sarà una carrellata
di tutta quella che è stata
la storiografia grafica dell'Amleto
e quindi vedere come, nei secoli,
è cambiato la rappresentazione
e la raffigurazione di questa storia.
Fino ad arrivare ad oggi,
quando ci saranno, appunto,
le vostre proposte.
Un'altra sezione importante
sarà la genealogia:
e nella genealogia ci sarà
una carrellata, di nuovo,
di quelli che sono stati
gli amleti prima di Amleto,
da Tito Livio a Saxo Grammaticus,
fino ad arrivare a Shakespeare,
che l'ha consegnata poi alla modernità,
ai capitoli che sono nel Wilhelm Meister,
o al settimo capitolo
dell'"Ulysses" di Joyce.
Fino ad arrivare ai giorni nostri,
quando nel cinema, lo vediamo
in moltissime parti, è presente.
Dietro di me ci saranno delle immagini,
un riassunto di un minuto,
una carrellata di come è presente
nel cinema, nella televisione
e anche nei cartoni animati Shakespeare,
perché si arriva fino a Re Leone.
Nel Re Leone, che è un Amleto
nella giungla, in sostanza,
gli sceneggiatori si sono anche divertiti
a mettere l'immagine di Scar,
lo zio che è usurpatore del trono,
che dialoga con un teschio,
che è una classica imagerie amletica.
Quindi tutte queste sezioni,
messe insieme,
struttureranno la forma
e la struttura portante
di quella che è questa operazione.
SB: Che cosa saranno, allora,
gli esiti di questa operazione,
quali saranno i risultati
di questo sforzo collettivo,
di questa avventura
letteraria internazionale?
Il primo, il più canonico,
sarà una installazione cartacea, un libro,
un libro che sarà pubblicato
da alcuni dei principali
editori internazionali:
in Italia avremo Feltrinelli;
in Francia Gallimard
con il marchio "La Table Ronde";
in Spagna Anagrama,
che lo diffonderà anche in Sudamerica,
in Olanda Aetheneum,
e presto anche un editore inglese.
Questo libro sarà il tentativo
di realizzare, dal basso,
un'altissima edizione di Amleto,
quindi in particolare
una traduzione collettiva
che sarà la prima mai realizzata,
e un apparato critico collettivo
che si avvarrà
dell'eterogeneità dei saperi,
della molteplicità dei punti di vista
da cui sarà guardato
e riscoperto l'Amleto.
Una seconda cosa
particolarmente importante
sarà anche quello che vogliamo chiamare
un tentativo di trasformare il rapporto
tra gli studenti e i loro testi di studio.
Gli studenti, in qualche modo,
contribuiranno a scrivere
il loro testo di studio,
il testo su cui loro studieranno
o su cui studieranno
gli studenti che verranno dopo di loro.
Perché? Perché verranno invitati
ad utilizzare in modo creativo
i testi della critica letteraria.
Quindi immaginate gli studenti
che li ricevono, li leggono
e li devono utilizzare:
non più semplicemente mandare a memoria,
ma utilizzare per tradurre,
per annotare l'Amleto.
Immaginate anche la possibilità
di questi studenti,
che per la prima volta
saranno davanti al video,
saranno davanti ad internet,
saranno anche sui social network
perché si potrà annotare
anche sui social network
e potranno rispondere
che non stanno perdendo tempo,
stanno studiando, anche se stanno
davanti a Facebook.
Quindi l'idea è quella di trasformare
in modo dinamico, partecipato e diffuso
il rapporto che gli studenti hanno
con la tradizione scritta,
sempre naturalmente sotto la supervisione
prima dei loro professori
e poi, in seconda battuta,
degli editor di Global Hamlet,
che controlleranno il tipo di cose
che saranno proposte.
Alla fine una delle cose più importanti
sarà naturalmente il sito stesso,
che ci piace chiamare un libro vivente.
Un libro vivente è, sostanzialmente,
un libro che viene
continuamente aggiornato,
che si trasforma;
è un libro che, incapace
di contenere il mondo,
si è aperto al mondo
e si trasforma continuamente in mondo.
Internet ha reso possibile
questa idea di opera aperta,
di opera che si trasforma continuamente;
e questa sarà una delle possibilità
importanti del futuro:
un nuovo tipo di letteratura e di libri,
che saranno continuamente aggiornati
e riscritti dai loro lettori
e che in questo modo
abbatteranno la distinzione
tra il lettore e l'autore.
D'altra parte anche questo è un modo,
quest'idea dei libri viventi,
Hamlet è il primo di una serie
di quelli che vogliamo chiamare
"Collective classics" -
di reinterpretare l'idea di cultura.
La parola cultura sorge nel Rinascimento,
intorno al Cinquecento,
ed è una potentissima metafora.
Cultura viene dall'idea di coltivazione:
"coltura" della mente,
coltivare una mente
con pensieri, idee, testi,
con tutto quello che la può rendere
più fertile, appunto;
e questo è un tentativo,
attraverso i Collective Classics,
di una coltivazione,
nella mente collettiva,
delle opere seminali dell'umanità.
In qualche modo, un libro vivente
è già Wikipedia, naturalmente:
ma Wikipedia è il libro che ha mostrato
alcune delle potenzialità importanti
della cultura digitale.
Se c'è un libro per ogni età
della storia culturale dell'uomo,
allora la Bibbia, l'Iliade e l'Odissea
sono i libri della cultura orale,
della tradizione orale,
sono i libri della voce;
l'Encyclopédie francese,
che nasce nel tempo
della Rivoluzione Francese,
è il libro dell'età della scrittura;
e Wikipedia è il libro dell'età digitale.
E in qualche modo riesce
a porre insieme, sintetizzare
le due concezioni di libro
che l'hanno preceduta,
quella della voce
e quella della scrittura,
perché si può dire
che la scrittura, su Internet,
sia voce scritta, voce che rimane
e scrittura che si trasforma.
Ecco, allora l'idea di Global Hamlet
è quella di applicare, per la prima volta,
l'intelligenza collettiva
alla letteratura e alle arti.
Se Wikipedia ha creato
un archivio collettivo,
creare in questo caso un autore collettivo
e anche, se vogliamo così dire,
un attore collettivo.
Amleto, durante tutta l'opera,
vive continuamente sul palcoscenico,
e porta sul palcoscenico
gli altri personaggi dell'opera.
Quello che dice Amleto
è che tutti sono attori
e che tutti sono, in qualche modo,
autori dell'opera che stanno recitando.
Tutti sono attori,
tutti hanno le loro entrate
e le loro uscite.
E questa è stata la nostra.
Vi ringrazio della vostra attenzione.
(Applausi)